UH OH FELLAS, LOOKS AS THOUGH WE HAVE COMPANY.
- AND WHAT THE HELL ARE YOU
NIGGRAS DOIN' OUT HERE?
- WE ARE THE TIME HATERS.
WE TRAVELED ALL THE WAY
BACK THROUGH TIME...
TO CALL YOU A CRACKER.
- YOU BETTER
WATCH YOUR MOUTH.
- ACTUALLY, YOU BETTER
WATCH YOUR MOUTH, WHITE BOY,
BEFORE I PUT THESE GATORS
UP YOUR ASS
AND SHOW YOUR INSIDES
SOME STYLE.
- THAT'S ENOUGH!
- I CAN'T BE NO SLAVE, SILKY.
- OH, GOOD GOD.
- LOOK, SILKY,
HE DONE PULLED OUT A WHIP.
- NICE WHIP.
THIS HERE IS A PISTOL.
REACH FOR THE SKY, HONKY.
- HONKY?
HONKY?
- HONKY IS A RACIAL EPITHET
USED FOR WHITE PEOPLE.
WAS MADE POPULAR BY
A MAN NAMED GEORGE JEFFERSON
IN THE 1970s.
YOU SEE,
HE AND HIS WIFE, WEEZY,
HAD A DRY CLEANING BUSINESS,
SO THEY MOVED ON UP
TO THE EAST SIDE,
TO A DELUXE APARTMENT
IN THE SKY.
THEY FINALLY GOT
A PIECE OF THE PIE.
CONVOLUTED STORY, I'LL ADMIT,
BUT THE POINT IS THIS:
THAT IN THE FUTURE,
ALL BLACK PEOPLE WILL BE FREE.
- IN A SECOND, ALL RIGHT,
THIS IS WHAT STOPPED
THE WHOLE SHOW.
THIS STOPPED--
I MEAN, LITERALLY,
THE WHOLE EPISODE CAME
TO A SCREECHING HALT RIGHT HERE.
AS A MATTER OF FACT,
I CAN PREDICT THIS EPISODE
COMING TO A SCREECHING HALT
RIGHT NOW.
BUT I'LL SHOW IT.
- WHEN'S WE GONNA BE FREE?
- THAT IS A GOOD QUESTION,
MY MAN.
HOW ABOUT NOW-ISH?
[gunshot]
- [grunts]
- APPARENTLY,
SHOOTING A SLAVE MASTER
ISN'T FUNNY TO ANYBODY
BUT ME AND NEAL.
IF I COULD,
I'D DO IT EVERY EPISODE.
SO THAT WAS THAT ONE.